ziemlich krass Kalcher Candela bei
klicksom und ziemlich krass ist den
Jungs brennt es unter den Fingernägeln
über die Kommentare unter dem letzten
Interview mit ihnen bei klicksum zu
sprechen da ging es heiß her und hoch
her zum Thema Integration und lustig
auch eine Menge Applaus bei diesem
Interview also bis dann bleibt dran und
wenn er nichts verpassen wollt
abonnieren nicht
vergessen schon
se so hier guten Tag
mich he wir wohn
hier sensationell sie haben mich nicht
vergessen das ist
gut schon bisschen GEF wie ist die
Lage die Lage ist gut ja ja ja wir sind
in eine gute Position jetzt deswegen
sind wir hierellen okay in welcher
Position seid ihr jetzt ich gebe euch
mal das Mikro weil sonst also ich
definier Moment da sind wir
etwas vor Mittelfeld also wir sind auf
dem Weg zum Stürmer nach lange
Trainingspause wir haben uns vorbereitet
gut auf die neue Saison und wir sind
sehr motiviert und jetzt geht's erst los
wir freuen uns auf dieses Jahr ihr habt
jetzt direkt ich WE ist euer Rhythmus
immer ein Jahr gewesen war das immer so
ich habe jetzt nicht genau verfolgt oder
ist das heute im musikbsiness so dass
man jedes Jahr eine Platte machen muss
also bei habe ich das inzwischen das
Gefühl die machen sogar zweimal im Jahr
ein Album nicht ein Album oder Mixtapes
oder sonst andersrum
andersrum ja also ich glaube dass man
heutzutage gar nicht mehr so lange vom
Markt verschwinden kann egal wie man
heißt welche welche Band man ist bestes
Beispiel rihana da ich glaube die bringt
jetzt alle jedes halbe Jahr ein neues
Album raus gerade eben ist noch diese SM
S&M Geschichte bei mir im Ohr und schon
ist irgendwie eine neue Single da vom
nächsten Album krass und ja wir sind
jausagen die rihana Deutschland und
deswegen bringen wir jetzt auch schon
wieder neues Album raus wir sind in den
Startlöchern alles irgendwie cool cool
und das heißt wir sind in den
Startlöchern das neue Album aka flat
rate gen und wir freuen uns weil jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen spannt wir haben
wir so unsere Arbeit getan und jetzt
irgendwie malen die Mühlen und es ist
sehr cool und wir freuen uns natürlich
hier wieder mit dir da zu sein weil es
war war sehr spannend und das
allerspannendste waren ich nicht nur die
fantastischen Unsummen an Klickzahlen
die ihr generiert sondern auch die
Kommentare was da sich teilweise für
eine braune rassistische Suppe tummelt
das war schon sehr interessant zu lesen
nur weil nur weil in der Überschrift
stand so die Deutschen sollen sich
integrieren es war echt geil es war geil
weil das W interessant weil es wirklich
mit das ja wie soll ich sagen
anstößigste war was wir jemals gemacht
haben ja ja ist das äh ja ich bin da
noch unschlüssig ist das was Gutes dass
die Leute sich ich sag mal so auten und
das zur Diskussion kommt oder ist es was
ich bin erschrocken weil es war ah okay
nicht jeder hat Humor Humor ist ein
zartes flänzchen aber es war ja
humoristisch gemeint dass sich die
Deutschen integrieren soll wir wir sind
ja selber Bestandteil von Deutschland
hier Deutschland ist super wir sind alle
deutsch und Zahlen h Steuern alles und
und arbeiten hier und leben hier und
fühlen uns wohl und das da so wirklich
Anonymität des Internets so eine so eine
krassen ohne Worte also das war echt
erschreckend also ist echt krass weil
ich würde so Leute mal gerne auch
persönlich treffen wie die dann in
Wirklichkeit aussehen ja ich weiß nicht
manchmal ist es so wie bei Autofahrern
die sind so hier hinter ihren
gasscheiben und da kann man dann mal
ordentlich auf die Hupe treten und aber
wenn man dann Drau aussteigt dann wird's
problematisch also man steigt eigentlich
lieber nicht aus habe ich oft das Gefühl
also ich bin mein Ernst bist ein
lustiger Typ und cooles Format und so
aber das haben wir sehr genossen weil so
super cool auch diese einzelnen Fragen
die Fanfragen und so aber die Kommentare
waren schon also 50% von den waren schon
gesalzen Alter mm
was ich sag mal stört es euch verletzt
es euch oder
na ist auf jeden Fall erstmal
erschreckendes zu sehen dass anscheinend
so viel auch tatsächlich rassistisches
Potenzial irgendwie sich im Internet
humummelt also gerade auch weil die halt
da nicht zu erkennen sind und so dann
geben sie sich vielleicht noch waliger
in ihren Argumentation und so und das
zeigt auch dass tatsächlich dieses Thema
so so so so Schlimmes ist immer noch
nicht irgendwie vom Tisch ist dass es
tatsächlich noch existiert und auch wenn
man es vielleicht im Alltag nicht so
spürt und so irgendwie damit in Kontakt
kommt dann sieht man das an solchen
Punkt dass da wirklich so so ein so ein
ja so ein so ein Potenzial irgendwie ist
und das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schön
zu sehen aber es war auf jeden Fall sehr
interessant dass man das mal so
mitbekommen was sowas gibt dass dass das
überhaupt noch so existent ist ja weil
genau also ich finde das nämlich
eigentlich wichtig dass man so überhaupt
weil vieles wird einfach ich sag mal
unter den Teppich geschwiegen so das
Problem gibt's nicht oder das da wollen
wir nicht drüber reden weil das ist ja
doof wenn man es drüber reden weil dann
kommt erst nach oben aber eigentlich
finde ich dass eigentlich alles auf den
Tisch sollte und dass man es
ausdiskutiert auf jeden Fall müssen die
Sachen auf den Tisch also es hat uns
auch unter andem gezeigt dass unsere
Arbeit auch nicht zu Ende ist weil wir
sehen uns als deutsche Band und für uns
ist es das Selbstverständlichste der
Welt aber für ganz ganz viele leider
immer noch nicht und das sind auf jeden
Fall immer wieder so kleine pixer ey
viele Leute haben es noch nicht kapiert
so und im Endeffekt glaube ich schon
dass man dass man die Sachen immer
wieder ansprechen muss auch wenn wenn es
Leute leid sind also das ich wiederhole
mich zum Taus tausend Mal wurden bei
phöniix mal in so einer Runde gefragt
integrationsrunde ob wir uns als
vorzeigeausländer sehen und das und die
Frage war war seh sehr intellektuell
gedacht und so weiter aber ich fande in
der in dieser
Frage steckte das ganze Problem der
Gesellschaft so ein bisschen weil wir
uns nicht als Ausländer sehen wir sind
hier geboren die meisten haben ein
mindestens ein ein deutsches Elternteil
die meisten haben mindestens einen
deutschen
Pass auch auch sehr
gutchuldigung nein aber aber aber also
unsere Arbeit ist nicht zu Ende und wir
machen weiter natürlich nein aber wo ist
die Arbeit was kann man tun weil ich
finde es ist einfach wahnsinig viel
nicht ausdiskutiert und es wird wah in
die falsche Richtung deswegen fand ich
euren Beitrag beim letzten Mal absolut
auf dem Punkt weil ja gerade das Thema
war ja man muss sich ja auch sozial
integrieren letztlich es geht ja um
soziale Integration es geht ja gar nicht
darum ob sich ein Ausländer oder
sonstwerer integriert es geht darum dass
man eine Gemeinschaft bildet und das ist
nicht der Fall und das wird aber nicht
diskutiert und da fand ich euren Beitrag
halt super weil der genau das am anderen
Ende mal angepackt hat cool freut uns
auch also ich wollte jetzt auch gar
nicht jetzt irgendwie so so ernst super
ernst werden oder so aber das war schon
sehr interessant und wenn man drüber
nachdenkt so Piratenpartei und freies
Internet für alle dann gruselt mich auch
ein bisschen wenn ich so wenn ich sowas
lese wenn so rohe verbale Gewalt sich
formuliert im Internet einfach so purer
Hass wie bei den Gladiatoren Spielen in
Rom so einfach blutrünstige Kommentare
so so meine Freunde so richtig
schlechtten Deutsch geschrieben meine
Freunde Segen dass ihr voll die Kanak
seid aber ich finde euch cool culter
aber ich finde dich cool kalultcher was
soll ich den sagen dann frage ich mich
so okay in welcher Schule bist du denn
dass deine Freunde sagen wir sind
Kanacken so und lauter so eine
Kommentare so ey ihr ihr weiß nicht was
Opfer Opfer von der Straße Ausländer
drecksasylanten und so ist lustig so
aber auch so in so ganz schlimmen
Deutsch teilweise wo ich so denke okay
also so what the eigentlich so
komisch war interessant aber auch sehr
lustig mit dir
okay das verzit ist auf jeden Fall man
muss diese Themen aussprechen und wir
sind dafür und weil erst dann kann man
überhaupt was verändern inem die Leute
sich überhaupt damit auseinandersetzen
und Gedanken drüber machen und das haben
sie ja getan und und ist der Anfang halt
soll weitergehen wir sind jetzt im
ernsten aber trotzdem will ich auch noch
mal drauf ihr engagiert euch da ja auch
neben eurer Musik
aktiv alle Kids sind habe ich gelesen
afica rise wir hab noch ein Projekt was
war Action Kid Action Kids also das
macht ja auch und das da dreht sich ja
glaube ich immer um Bildung und um
umlich um Jugendliche und ist das ein
Problem das haben wir ein
Bildungsproblem weil ich habe vorhin
eine Autorin eines schulfrustbch also
das Buch heißt
Schulfrust interviewt und die meint z.
ein riesen Problem ist
dass bestimmte Sachen einfach nicht
sanktioniert werden also nicht
verurteilt werden werden z.B dass die
Leute sich gegenseitig dass sie sagen du
Jude das stört mich z.B wahnsinnig ich
finde in unserem Land darf nie ein darf
das nicht als schimpwort benutzt werden
und das finde ich schrecklich und ich
finde auch wirklich schlimm dass es
unserem Bildungssystem dann nicht sofort
gesagt das ist ein riesenprem wir sofort
was tun hier darf keiner dieses Wort
benutzen und zwar nicht weil es verboten
ist sondern weil er es versteht weil er
eben gebildet ist ist das so euer
Hintergrund warum ihr das macht dass er
sagt bildung ist der Schlüssel oder ist
das auch also ich finde dass Bildung
ehrlich gesagt
glaube ich ein einer von drei Grundlagen
zum Weltfrieden sein sollte oder kann
also jeder sollte Zugang zu Bildung
haben zu zu Wasser und irgendwie zu
einem zu essen und einem Dach überm Kopf
so W wä die Welt glaube ich irgendwie
mehr in Ordnung Bildung ist ganz ganz
wichtig also es geht fast einher mit
irgendwie was zu essen und zu trinken
weil ohne Bildung das sieht man ja auch
bei bei so vielen Konflikten die
entstehen ohne dass man sich selbst ein
Kopf macht und fähig ist dazu sich
selbst den Kopf zu machen weil man nicht
lesen kann z.B ist man einfach auch so
schlatan ausgeliefert so irgendwelchen
Hasspredigern oder ist egal von welcher
Religion das ist aber es Bildung ist
ganz ganz ganz essentiell also
definitiv gut euer Album ist aber jetzt
hat mit Bildung relativ wenig zu tun
genau unser Album
ist ja okay okay pass auf ich weiß guter
Bogen also unser Album Null mit Bildung
zu tun weil wir Schrei auch Flatrate mit
Ja Nein aber es geht mehr um Spaß um
feiern um
ich habe festgestellt es ich weiß nicht
der wiffelste Song ist es ist auf eurem
Album der da sich darum dreht wie reiße
ich eine Frau auf oder wie werde ich von
der Frau aufgerissen das lusties
natürlich inspirieren uns Frauen
wahnsinnig zum Lieder machen das ist
eine super Inspirationsquelle die nie
versiegt
hoffentlich jetzt Bildungsauftrag aber
es ist ziemlich schwer ehrlich gesagt
oder noch schwerer coole Party Songs zu
machen oder coole sage ich mal jetzt
aufrei party was auch immer Songs zu
machen das ist viel schwieriger ich
gesagt als über ernste Themen zu
sprechen we erzthen gibt so so viele
aber es ist nicht einfach ein coolen
Partys Song zu machen wo man nicht sagt
ich feier ich ma Party lass die kcken
knallen sondern wo man das versucht
irgendwie anders auszudrücken genauso
blöd ist ja auch wenn man Liebessong
macht und dann so ich liebe dich singt
oder rappt oder Liebe ist so so
liebevoll ist halt man muss Hal ander
usdrucken und das ist viel schwerer sich
locker zu machen und ein coolen Party
Song dann auchch auf Deutsch zu machen
den jeder versteht weil ganz ehrlich die
ganzen englischen Sachen sind ja von den
Lyrics teilweise das
ist unter die Leute so schuidbi die
verstehen es halt nicht so richtig ja
und und das ist also gar nicht so easy
ehrich gesagt so Party Tracks zu machen
das F eine Königsdisziplin würde ich
sagen ja wir beherrschen sie ganz gut
inzwischen W ich sagen jo ist das ist
das so seid ihr da inzwischen gelandet
als Marke so das ist unser Auftrag im im
Auftrag der guten Party unterwegs in
Deutschland nö nö und ja ne ich würde
sagen eigentlich hat sich da nicht
sonderlich viel geändert seit Tag 1 wir
versuchen immer noch eine ganze Menge
Themen zu vereinen und auf ein Album zu
kriegen und ich das ist eigentlich jetzt
auch glaube ich zum fünften Mal sehr
sehr gut gelungen dass wir einerseits
Party Songs machen oder sehr fröhliche
sehr leichte Songs machen wo man jetzt
nicht sich hinsetzen muss und erstmal
eine fte Stunde weinen muss bevor man
wieder weiter tanzen kann ja also darum
geht's uns nicht unsere Leute zu
frustrieren unsere Fans zu sagen alles
total scheiße bringt euch um das ist
natürlich nicht der Sinn von kaa Candela
trotzdem haben wir nach wie vor in
unseren Songs auch Inhalte die die
Menschen draußen interessieren wo man
drüber nachdenken kann wo man anstößt
zum Nachdenken im weitsten Sinne
sozialkritische Texte Themen ohne jetzt
da z stehen und zu sagen mach das mal
lieber so ja aber ich glaube das ist
eigentlich der Faden der sich durchzieht
durch fünf Kiter kanela Alben dass wir
da ganz coole Mischung hingekriegt haben
und dass wir auch den Anspruch haben
dass man auch zu den ernsteren Songs den
Popo schwingen kann und bisschen Pass
haben kann und das ist bei Flat R
eigentlich Killer geil gelungen und
unsere messagees werdet bloß nicht
deutsch son seid ihr vorzeige Ausländer
im eigenen Land genau ja wobei das ist
manche beschreiben das so dass in ihren
Klassen oder letz mal eine Dok das
wirklich da gibt's eben Klassen
inzwischen wo sich deutsche als wo
deutsche Integrationsprobleme haben
stimmt ja auch gibt ja auch genug von
okay aber könnten sich alle mal ein
bisschen integrieren die und die nicht
deutschen auch also irgendwo in der
Mitte liegt die Wahrheit glaube ich ja
man darf halt nicht vergessen dass
dieses Land hier auf einer Reise ist das
verändert sich ständig und dann veränder
sich auch aber ich wollte mal auf eure
Songs kommen gut gut gut sehr schön son
wer ich ja auch von der Plattenfirma
gekillt wenn ich nicht über das Album
rede ja das ist wirklich hat böse
Konsequenzen bezahlen die dich nee
bezahlen mich nicht bezahlen die euch
n aber der ich sag mal den Dreh habt ihr
raus ist oder der ist den doch habt
rausgekriegt oder hat sich ergeben mit
Hammer ja ja kann so sagen kann man kann
man so sagen war das so ein Moment wo er
dachtet hey das ist es da wollten wir
hin oder war das Schwurbel Schwurbel
oder ist es oder war es gezielt
zielgerichtet eigentlich wollten wir
eigentlich wollten wir sowas nie machen
so wir dachten so ja nee eigentlich
wollen wir keinen Erfolg haben und auch
keine tollen Songs machen auf einmal war
der Song da und wir haben so überlegt
wollen wir den wirk veröffentlichen
jetzt oder werden wir dann am Ende zu
erfolgreich ist es dann noch cool wir
haben uns getraut das zu machen und äh
ja leider ist in die Hose gegangen
dummerweise nach hinten voll nach hinten
erfolgreich geworden mir leid aber es
war mehr schwobel schwobel ne auf jeden
Fall also es war nicht geplant was nicht
aber wir haben schon gespürt dass
irgendwie ein cooles Lied ist aber
wusste jetzt nicht so ah das wirde jetzt
so und so erfolgreich aber schon
natürlich ein cooler Song der uns
gefallen hat die haben wir auch gleich
als erstes von dem Album gemacht und ähm
ja war schicksalshaft weil 6 Wochen plus
1 ja nicht nur das auch bis heute
irgendwie eine halbe Million Mal
verkauft und und kommt jedes jedes Jahr
in die Charts immer echt warte
warte jeden Sommer und die mus
vorstellen war jetzt schon wieder über
drei Monate in in den Charts einfach
einfach wieder so reingeschaut weil sich
die Leute es wieder gekauft haben und
der ist von 2007 der Song und ist schon
irgendwie cool und bisschen bisschen
cool es hat uns einfach auf mit einem
Schlag auch zu zu allen Leuten in in
nach Hause gebracht die uns so vorher
halt nicht auf dem Schirm hatten und das
ist ganz cool also da gibt's nur
positive Sachen dran ehrlich gesagt weil
wir sind ja dann auch nicht irgendwie
dran zerbrochen oder gescheitert weil es
hat einfach wir haben es einfach so
genommen und haben dann weitergemacht
alles cool das war es gibt gab mal ein
das habe ich Falco hat das gesagt ich
habe das GL ich irgendwann schon mal
erwähnt als der ein riesen den ersten
riesen ich glaub Amadeus genau war
Nummer ein Amerika da war der total
traurig da war der total traurig ja
verstehe ich aber warum da
wahrscheinlich eins geworden ist und
Deutschland nicht nein es war auch in
Deutschland eins nein ach so warum war
fo
traurig kommt nicht drauf ihr kommt
nicht drauf oder es kann auch sein dass
dass die Drohung Einspiel damit zu tun
hat nein du weißt du meinst du we also
also ich also ich glau ich glaube also
bzw gibt's da wirklich eine Antwort von
ih kenst nee ich weiß s nicht aber ich
kann es nur vermuten weil ich habe
manchmal so Gefühl von Traurigkeit wenn
alles zu gut läuft also wenn z.B
wirklich Erfolg da ist Kohle da ist Frau
Haus weiß ich nicht was alles irgendwie
so Boot Dings Hund weißt du ne fünfter
Ferrari so ne SAS BL halt da denke ich
mir mal so da fühle ich so eine Lehre so
eine so eine so ja vol es muss ja auch
was da sein sage ich mal wo man diese
ständige Unzufriedenheit die auch
antreibt wo man so denkt Scheiße bei dem
Lied und es ist halt auch bei jedem
Album so ne bei dem Lied hätte man ja
noch das und das Schrauben können und
das und das anders machen vielleicht im
Nachhinein aber irgendwann muss man es
ja abgeben ne und das Hal ich fühle
manchmal so eine Lehre wenn es wenn es
zu gut läuft und dann bin ich wirklich
ein bisschen traurig und und deprimiert
also kein scheß also letztlich ist es so
bei bei Falco gewesen der sagt ich so
ein Erfolg werde ich nie wieder
haben das war aber bei euch ist es
Antrieb aber du hatest am Anfang die
Mühlen malen jetzt das Album ist raus
ist das ist es nicht irgendwann auch mal
eine Mühle so nach dem jetzt wieder ein
Album wieder oder ist der Erfolg euer
Antrieb ist das eine Droge wo man sagt
ich
geil ja meine Damen und
Herren mittlerweile ist es schon
so dass wir uns sage ich mal dass wir
uns über Freundes machen zu dürfen weil
wie viel Bands haben überhaupt die
Chance so viel Alben immer rauszubringen
und gehört zu werden also es gibt viele
Bands die bringen Alben raus aber die
werden nicht gehört und ich glaube wir
haben so ein krassen musiküberfluss also
man kann man kann gar nicht die die
ganze coole Musik hören mittlerweile und
dass wir so eine Plattform Plattform
haben und noch ein Album machen dürfen
wieder auf Tour gehen dürfen wieder
hoffentlich ausverkaufen werden und so
weiter das ist einfach ein ganz großes
Privileg und dafür haben wir von Tag 1
dafür gearbeitet wir haben seit Tag 1
auch daran geglaubt also wir haben ja
nie gezweifelt dass wir die krassest
sind
so
danke MWe muss jetzt einfach vor Augen
führen dass man das machen darf
eigentlich weil das ist wirklich auch
wenn viele Leute sagen dann sagen oft ey
geil man ihr macht ihr könnt geht wieder
auf Tour und so das ist einfach ein
Privileg so und so muss man das auch
sehen ihr seid ja auch die ab wenn man
von den Amerikanern abseht sieht
die auf weitem Feld relativ einzigartig
ja jetzt habe ich zusag
rit se abgesehen von den
amerikan Millionen Leute
sindlich ich sag mal Rana Lady Gaga
ansonsten spielt ja auf den Topf top
topfplätzen auf den topfplätzen kaum mal
einer an der Rolle oder also was Disco
Dance
und mit deutschen
Texten na es gibt schon also ich glaube
vielleicht kann man das noch ein
bisschen eng Hammer wird immer gespielt
Berlin City wird immer gespielt movid
wird glaube ich auch noch immer gespielt
Monster wird immer
gespielt ja man kann sagen deutsche also
deutsche Party Songs glaube ich haben
wir uns schon guten Status
erarbeitet also generell viele deutsche
Songs laufen ja auf jeden Fall aber
viele sind auch sehr so zur Zeit gerade
auch so dies singer songwriter sehr
melancholisch und so und ich glaube wenn
dann wieder ein Deutscher partyong ein
guter deutscher Party Song ist ist
irgendwie seltener finde ich in der in
der Hitparade sag man noch ja den Chart
sag heute okay Ch auch gehört als
fy Song ja ja aber unterscheidet der
singer songwriter Song der der läuft
meinwen auch 20 Wochen aber dann ist er
weg und dann wird er nicht mehr gespielt
würde ich würde ich behaupten ich hätte
jetzt mal diese kühne
These ja aber also jetzt unter uns ne
es wäre natürlich auch nicht so schlecht
in die Sphären von von Unheilig
vorzustoßen so mit einer Million
irgendwie wä jetzt auch nicht schlecht
gut aber das war glaube ich auch das
meist verkaufte Album überhaupt wenn ich
richtig
informiert neeter nein nicht Peter Fox
nicht West Hagen nicht grö Meer Unheilig
es war Unheilig das meist verkauft in
diesen Zeiten das meist verkaufte Album
Unheilig und
dann und dann aber auch Peterle Peterle
hat
auch ne Peter Peter Fox aber Peter maff
verkauft der so also
das wäre schon eigentlich ganz geil so
ich meine Peter Fox ja W dann in unsere
Richtung auch sage ich mal ein bisschen
rhythmischer
sprech runter und da kennt man auch
finde ich gut wenn wir uns da noch so in
die Richtung Vorarbeiten also aber Party
Songs ich mein ja außer jetzt mal so
club banger außer uns und den arzen
gibt's wenig ja wenig stimmt die arzen
die zzen sind zzen Alter ja absolut
richtig cool aber die gehen schon in
andere Richtung ja nee sind aber coole
säu ja machen gute Sachen woll was
zusammen machen mal gucken
ja okay was habt ihr für ein Gefühl für
ein Gefühl dieses
Gefühl dieses Gefühl
inegen lass alles stehen lass alles
liegen es wir ewig so ewig so
weit wir haben schnell mal so zum Song
gemacht zusammfas scheie muss auf Album
Delux Verion genau vielen
Dank so aber ihr wisst ja es geht
weiter